we're just walking down my street in my
neighborhood this was last night and I
smiled at a woman who's walking her dog
you know like a normal a normal smile
not a creepy smile like a no-good normal
smile just the kind that's like yeah I
forget what it was
[ __ ] when it was in the moment it was so
natural I don't know but it was normal
just the kind that says hey I see you I
see you in your daughter see you you you
heis a De Niro I see you but I'm not
talking about like a huh you know wasn't
hey don't ask me what's in my basement
it wasn't that just a neighborly smile
but here's why I'm telling you she
didn't smile back no no we took yes I
don't know if you're kidding but I'm
serious I'm gonna hate it if I smiled a
stranger and she doesn't smile back I
immediately go from hi neighbor
- i'ma kill everyone you know I'm coming
after you and then Frank's it's a
betrayal here's why I think I care it's
it's social grace ping-pong I smile at
you you smile back
that's how it goes hit it back hitting
it back makes life better
a couple strangers smiling at each other
on the street everything's right in the
world in that moment when you hit it
back to me something babies are
high-fiving each other dogs are wearing
hats you know utopia dog dog hats it's
like back in the 50s again you know what
I mean we're dogs were okay I'm you
saying it's like a simpler time sepia
tone back when milk was delivered you're
out watering your lawn just like howdy
neighbor your southern all of a sudden
howdy neighbor you catch that I Love
Lucy program last night that gals are
whoo
well it's 3:30 time to start drinking
hard liquor with a huge orange slice cuz
it's the nineteen fifties what I'm
saying is life is hard hit it back
hitting a back makes life better how I
say laugh at jokes indiscriminately
what are you judging jokes and your
little brain laboratory was it good
laugh why cuz laughing is the best my
dad tells three jokes one he calls
ketchup Irish gravy
he's gonna be so happy you laugh I told
you Peter
Killa screw the Irish use it as a gravy
Irish guy ray goes ox he calls coffee
coffee even though he's not from New
York and he ends every phone call by
saying keep in touch with yourself
that's true regardless of who it's with
he's like alright senator thank you so
much keep in touch with yourself I laugh
I laugh like you did that's good I laugh
every time why because laughing at me is
so much more fun than not I got your
pops I'll hit it back just like you
taught me to laugh we all die someday
laugh it up here's how I hit it back my
last name is Holmes so I got a lot of
what up homes I get that a lot
and yes I've heard what up homes a lot a
million times but I love it why because
it means they're trying to play people
are being silly with me it's so much
better than talking to me like you're
interviewing me for a job at
hewlett-packard
it's like Peter well does it a Peter of
Holmes Holmes you say I have no comment
on that play beside I love when people
say what up homes because it means I get
to hit it back you say what up homes to
me and your name is Ana guess what
calling you banana
hell I'm calling you banana before you
say what up homes what is this the DMV
you're been in Hannah's Ana's Susanna's
you're all but innocent it
indiscriminate bananas all of you here's
another one this actually happened if
I'm at a bank and I comment to the
teller on my overdraft fee if I go whoa
that's huge
and Daryl probably Daryl
he felt like a Darrell if Terrell behind
the glass and he goes that's what she
said I could judge ya with a rain cloud
over me not funny
shut up laughs I got you Darrell I don't
not only do I laugh I don't judge I
applaud Darrell he means well
that's what she said Darrell you dog